cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com let me pull up this story
from the post millennial uh Biden's
approval rating among black Americans
down 17 points according to NBC in fact
it's so bad that Washington Post
downplayed their own polls two of them
that showed Trump winning by 10 points
10 points CNN had a segment
there were two polls one said ten and
one said nine I heard one go ahead sorry
so I I don't know how it how it works
necessarily but they have two different
polls of of you know and that's what
gets released to 538 or that's what 538
tracks and so you have Biden losing CNN
running a segment where they say
outright in the 2020 cycle we never saw
Trump pull this well against Biden at
all in aggregate Trump is beating Joe
Biden I'm imagining these people in New
York this judge why would he bang the
gavel to destroy the Trump organizations
he's crying he's in his room heart
beating racing going am I on the wrong
side of History I can't lose we can't
lose bang the gavel in violation of
their of their of what they once
believed or whatever they thought they
believed arresting Donald Trump
arresting his lawyers finding his
lawyers this reeks of someone crying
and frantic Panic tyranny is a
confession of weakness yes but these
people think they're fighting Nazis
they think they're saving the world from
fascism but the problem is that the
Nazis are the ones almost honored in
Canadian Parliament by the Prime
Minister but that's a problem for us
well it's uh you know having a problem
for them and then he says we have to
watch out for Russian disinformation I
don't think these people truly believe
they're fighting Nazis I believe they
say that I think they really believe it
I I think some of them might but I
imagine a lot of these people
uh when when you talk to uh I've talked
to high profile celebrities musicians
rock stars actors Etc and I'm sure you
guys have your experience with them as
well where they say things like look man
I can't I can't be involved they'll come
I'll be destroyed they're there are
likely in my opinion
high profile individuals in law
enforcement and the Judiciary
who thought to themselves
oh my God I can't believe what's
happening to my country these people
have gone crazy but if I speak up
they'll destroy me so I've got to just
keep my head down and play along and
hope I survive but uh oh they chose the
wrong side they chose the despots who
are going to lose in this country called
the United States and now they're
thinking to themselves if Trump wins
it's me
I have no choice but to do everything in
my power to make sure Trump can't do
that Trump's going to lock people up I'm
hoping so I believe there's a strong
possibility last time yeah but that was
different that was Trump thinking he
could play ball and now and and it was
not this crazy it was it was weird it
was wild but Trump said no we don't do
that we're not going to do that we're
not going to seem like the social norms
were still in place right but now
they're clearly off the table so I mean
if Trump does win and doesn't just jail
every single one of these people then
you know it's social right do you yeah
do you think he if I don't think he's
got a choice I mean what what what well
there have been a lot of times that
Trump has said that he would do
something yeah he doesn't follow through
I mean it's one of his biggest flaws I
think that but I feel like the reason
that Trump behaved the way that he did
when he was in office is because he
believed that he would be accepted by
The Establishment remember he the only
reason that he ran is because Barack
Obama mocked him at the dinner that was
the last straw that was the I truly
believe that was the last straw because
he wanted to prove that he was worth
worth their respect that he was that he
had earned and was worth being among the
elite and he thought once I'm president
they will go ahead and accept me and
that's the way he behaved and even up to
right at the very end when he gave my uh
General Millie an award and he gave
faucio an award the day before he left
office that was because he was looking
to placate them he see I I I assume I
have to assume that he sees now that
there is no there is no route for him to
be friendly that if he gets back into
office he has to take he has to take
control and he has to destroy the the
bureaucracy the point that you're making
about how he believed that people would
accept him that has been Trump's fatal
flaw his entire life I mean all like
that's Dave Chappelle's joke that he
came out of the house to say they're all
corrupt and then went back in right he
has always sort of wanted to return yeah
he wants that and he's wanted that his
whole he's wanted that his whole career
like none of the you know none of the
he was in real estate New York none of
the other real estate people or like the
you know the Architects or the
contractors or anybody they always were
talking out of two sides of their mouth
with him and he knew it yeah and he's he
hasn't liked it I mean that is Trump's
big problem is the need for approval
yeah because I mean if there's one thing
that you can say that's good about
DeSantis is he's all too autistic for
approval right well people have actually
this is a Common Thread among liberals
saying that Rhonda census is quite
literally they believe he genuinely has
autism yeah I know that's why I like him
but it's it's just not his time at the
moment but I I don't know man I I think
the the problem the problem with like
relying on like the great man to take
out the organized minority is that the
organized minority can lose lots of
times and still win or as the great man
just has to lose once then it's over
yeah right well I think he lost twice I
think it's uh I mean I we sorry I was
gonna say to clarify when I say we're
winning that's not to say that we own
the battlefield it means that we have
been pushed back pushed back and finally
now we have routed the advancing force
and their ranks are starting to break
that means on the battlefield we are in
a weakened position but we have begun a
successful Advance against this corrupt
ideology where if this trend continues
we do win
I don't know I I think I think they'll
find a way of screwing them I think that
oh sure sure but Trump's not the end-all
be-all I I think Trump is a is an avatar
of the rage felt by people in this
country for a long time and he's
absorbing more and more he's growing
bigger with each and I mean I hope so
well it it is I mean
the fact that you know Biden's approval
rating among black Americans going down
at the same time Trump is surging among
black Americans that is one of the most
terrifying statistics to Democrats it
was uh it's been reported several times
Wall Street Journal recently in the past
couple of years said if Democrats can't
maintain 20 or if I'm sorry 80 if at any
point the Republicans go past 20 black
support the Democrats cannot win sure
period but the and the argument for
Trump has never been stronger but I'm
very concerned about all of the salami
slice tactics that they're going to
employ you know the ballot harvesting
and whatever else it is that they do but
I uh
I'm I'm not confident what would make
you feel confident though like what
would change to make you feel confident
I mean or is it just a lost cause voting
would have to be done in person with
Pottery charts right that would make me
feel confident right I don't know while
there are all these other mechanisms I
I'm skeptical I don't think the
presidency is the end-all be-all it's
not what matters I think what matters is
the cultural shift the the problem is
the presidency has been accruing extra
powers and more Central authority over
the last few decades and so it becomes
this kind of totemic influential
position that legislates through
executive order yeah they're doing
things the way things should be done
right George Bush had a certain number
of executive orders and Obama had more
yeah Trump had more and now Biden and
Biden was unbelievably aggressive on the
first like week in the first day he had
like 20 or something yeah and then he
just carried this on literally doing
hundreds of them so it's the this this
is just what happens to Old republics
man yeah you know power centralizes they
don't last forever well let's let's
clarify
I'm not saying that the existing
structure of the United States is
preserved I'm saying there will be
something new coming from it I believe
the left are reactionary and and it's
always interesting how you define how
they try to Define what reactionary is
right the left will say we are reaction
areas because it makes no sense uh the
left explicitly claims to be Progressive
and they are progressive because what
they're trying to achieve is communism
yes yes what you're trying to achieve is
Classical liberalism and that's what you
had and that's where you're trapped in
this country with people who are at war
with you because they literally are just
psychotically obsessed with the end goal
of Communism and they find any roadblock
worthy of being destroyed no matter what
it is but a component of what they do is
reactionary and that they're trying to
rewind the clock I think we talked about
this a long time ago that the United
States uh maybe maybe not it's one of
the first countries with the concept of
individual meritocracy with without
without uh based on race national origin
religion Etc and the left is trying to
eliminate that they're trying to rewind
the clock to a time before we had this
classical liberal system that allowed
individual Merit
yes but the thing the thing is before
and after won't be the individualistic
classical liberal Republic you're
thinking of but the left are not trying
to go back to what was prior to the
United States they're trying to get to
an idealized future that they think will
come afterwards technically I would say
I would say I would say overwhelmingly
yes but that's why I say a component and
that is reactionary that's why a lot of
these words describe only only specifics
uh when to be honest with you you guys
are the reactionaries here right because
you want the 1776 America no no I
disagree do you know what the 1776
America I had a high fever it was not
good well but but
politically technologically obviously
you want things the answer is no I don't
right politically so it depends on what
your definition of progressive is right
I think that when you look at where this
country is that's the question right
well okay they talk about oh we're
progressives progressing where right
what so that's why I would say no I
actually want a changed future right I
want I want I think that that's uh we
need to
amend the Constitution
to clarify things and make them better
now I understand the political realities
of amending the Constitution opening the
door to your enemies two-thirds but
imagine if if there's a culture War and
the Communists are defeated and just
totally give up and they're not a
question anymore and the uh
constitutional Republican Republicans or
republicanists whatever you want to call
it say hey how can we we can how can we
amend the Constitution to improve upon
us it doesn't happen again for instance
the Second Amendment can be can be made
to include literally any any any arm any
accessory quite literally we need to mix
but I also want to point out that you
know I don't want to go back to a Time
pre-women suffrage I don't go back to a
time when a constitution was written
about the rights of men when men were
enslaved I don't want to go back to any
of that I want to see the realization of
uh our moral values I wasn't speaking to
I wasn't speaking to the literal point
of 1776 but this is the point I was not
trying to go back I was talking to the
spirit of the thing right but obviously
the Amendments came afterwards but so
and obviously they're good so if we're
saying reactionary as in go back to the
way things were that's a bad thing no we
don't want to do that no no I'm not I'm
not saying literally go back in time
what I'm saying is you're trying to
restore the Spirit of the American
Republic as it was originally conceived
because all of the good things that the
American Republic was conceived of all
of the founding fathers knew would be a
consequence of the American Republic
they just didn't have the political
Capital to be able to do it right there
and right agreed like all of you know a
lot of well not all a lot of the
founding fathers own slaves but wanted
to abolish slavery and things like this
right and so they knew that this was the
path that this would end up being done
on and so you want to return to that
Spirit but the thing is the progressives
have got a different interpretation of
this and they say okay yeah we want
freedom too we want freedom from
everything right freedom from Hunger
positive Freedom yeah and so they they
they their their version of progress
their ideal view of the future is
essentially what you could describe as
communism it's the freedom from
literally everything and you're trapped
in this country with these lunatics
right this is half your country that are
absolutely batshit that have
stigmatized the human body itself as an
oppressive thing reality itself is is a
form of Oppression as so now what do you
do with them like what how do you deal
with that well so
in terms of describe descriptions of
reactionary otherwise it's almost
pointless because you can make the
argument that everyone else is more
reactionary like to to what degree the
question is the the moral loading on the
on the terms I mean to be a progressive
say well you want children to be
completely liberated from any
relationship with their own parents
that's not that's horrible I don't if I
if it makes me a reaction we say no
children belong to their parents and
they should be in love and care for each
other then I'm a reactionary well right
but but should we should we we can we
can be dark with it I think we're
winning you want to know another reason
why I think one because the left is
substantially more likely to abort and
sterilize their children and the right
are encouraging people to have families
and have kids of course they control the
schools and also but look at what's
happening in this country with a
cultural shift with parental rights and
education look at the Loudoun County is
is literally 30 seconds away from this
building 30 seconds boom you're in
Loudon if you want to go to where the
schools are you drive a little bit more
but the parents are showing up and
they're saying hey we don't want this
stuff and the laws are getting passed
across the board now there may be
conflict between the the cult and the
free people of the United States don't
get me wrong but there's a major
cultural shift where uh this this is the
data that I often cite because I covered
this several years ago in the 2000s
studies several studies showed liberals
were having 1.5 kids conservatives are
having 2.05 surprise surprise 20 years
later you have Pew research showing
slightly more conservative young people
only a tiny tiny bit yeah which is which
is a marked shift because typically each
generation is more Progressive now
you're seeing parental resistance to
what these schools are trying to do
you're seeing more and more people like
us watching shows like this and others
saying outright no to this education
system advocating homeschooling and pod
learning and actively uh participating
in their school boards
with that in mind with the conservative
base and the Libertarians and the
post-liberals knowing they're coming for
your kids they are in trouble because
they don't have kids the same goes
socialists don't have kids they have
yours but if these families have become
a prize to this and have begun to push
back and resist now it's danger danger
territory for them because they don't
have kids I really feel like I really
like I understand what you're saying but
I feel like the the left wants fewer
people so the fact that they do they
have fewer people yeah that's why
they're gluing they want to the
sidewalks yeah exactly they want
significantly I believe that they
probably want around a million or two
human beings on earth like Pete like
that's really the goal 500 500 000 500
500 million okay
okay they're doing degrowth exactly
that's exactly where I was going
degrowth because they don't believe that
the the world can support it but let
them but the thing about the parents the
one thing about parents and I've talked
to moms for Liberty about this and I've
talked to other you know parents rights
Advocates
um parents go to school board meetings
parents talk to teachers parents like
you know deal with all of that stuff and
it doesn't matter that the Department of
Justice called them domestic extremists
it doesn't matter that the you know FBI
sought to investigate parents parents
just keep showing up because the stakes
for parents are way too high you know
once you have a kid like you look at
your child that's not just your future I
mean it's their future it's your future
it's the future of you know their
children it's so much more important the
question I have for everyone who listens
to this show do you want your children
to live in the Pod and eat the bugs yes
or no
so that I I it's not that it can't be
one I just don't think that well I'm
just going to broadly term the right
even though that is deeply inaccurate
right of characterizing I can't Freedom
faction the just the opposite it's the
opposition to the left right that really
is what we're talking about well I'm
just going to characterize it as the
right to the the ease of the
conversation resistance the resistance
the the problem they have is if you were
to look at the organizational capacity
the resources the number of people that
the left has active right now all over
the place uh it's staggering how much
more power the left has on the right
right I mean the the parents do have to
show up but the thing is there's only so
many times they can show up there's only
so much time they can take off work
there's only so many there's only so
much money that they could collectively
gather together to have like a lawsuit
against some Soros funded or whoever
funded billionaire activist organization
and these people being paid and will
always be paid and not only that like
treat this like a crusading faith and so
they get up in the morning Desiring to
do this you're trapped in this country
with essentially a bunch of religious
termite but I understand this but did
you know the founding fathers of the
United States thought that we would lose
the war for independence sure they were
saying many of the same things in a
similar way they were saying we can't
possibly win yeah you can't go against
the crowns impossible in fact we uh I
was reading about Lexington and Concord
the shot heard around the world and the
reason this is considered so pivotal for
the American Revolution was that prior
to the uh to the battles of Lexington
and Concord which were more of just like
like a handful of farmers fighting cops
essentially yeah basically no one
believed there would ever be arms raised
against regulars sure it was just no
because you have the Boston Massacre
where they're throwing rocks and stuff
basically a riot
and then
well a lot happened we'll put it that
way but this idea that simply because
you are up against Goliath means David
can't win I just don't think is correct
I think the issue with uh just a quick
thing here no one's coming to save us
right you had 16 000 French troops come
on that's true French French
professional church that's why these
these were the best in the world right
the French troops at the time the best
in the world right and they were at War
they were fighting war against Britain
that's not yeah they weren't helping
where did we get that there's a lot of
veterans
it's not literal yeah it's not literally
you know where where where where is the
support that's going to come externally
from an interested party who actively
wants to defeat the left it'll be the
other way around it'd be like you and
troops because
it's not literal troops if we're talking
figuratively where's the cultural
efforts the resources right the
resources needed to win whatever War
you're in if it was you know and see it
be boats if it's on land it's troops but
it's cultural fighting here and it's a
kind of social war that's going on where
could the reinforcements come from
we have we have gen Z like gen Z is more
conservative you know the kids who are
coming up now are more conservative they
have a much deeper interest and you know
their basic rights and also thinking
that all this stuff is trash they look
at their gay teachers waving flags
around and they roll their eyes with
disdain in the in the analogy of the
American Revolution you're correct we we
only won because of France but just a
quick thing mostly
what's the reading level of gen Zed the
reading level I don't know yeah right I
don't know I don't know about that like
yeah my son over the weekend was like
Mom do you know Hamlet I'm reading
Hamlet and I was like by by all means
good yeah but you're you escaped yeah I
escaped don't you homeschool your
literally December and no I don't
homeschool my child
in the in the direct analogy of the
United States we can point out the U.S
needed support we needed help sure uh
Quebec uh Quebec said no way we're not
getting involved and they would have
been the 14th colony there were other
colonies but in this instance I'm not so
sure we actually need that if the the uh
informed class of people in this country
are continually shifting away from The
Establishment narrative
it's going to be more V for Vendetta
than American Revolution sure it's going
to be that scene where the inspector
says eventually someone will do
something stupid and then it shows the
finger man shoot the little girl and
then the locals come out and say we just
don't care anymore and they got baseball
bars and crowbats baseball baseball bars
and crowbeds what the baseball bats and
crowbars V dies though right
but to be honest V chooses sure that was
kind of the point he was done he was
tired and so he decided to confront
um
uh what's the guy's name uh oh uh the VP
I I know the guy right I can't remember
his name I remember creedy yeah
um and I remember was it Prospero is it
what was that no brother no he was the
TV guy yeah I remember him yeah yeah but
anyway anyway the v v didn't have to he
he you know he he confronts sure but the
point is it's not about V himself right
you can maybe that's Trump you can say
Trump is it could be she's could be he's
happy but I would love to have an AI
movie generator just replace V with
Trump
he's like fighting and you couldn't do
that that technology exists right the
right doesn't have the right mindset to
win the war that's the thing because the
rights fighting to be left alone and
they're fighting to externally
out in other countries I mean I think of
like Eastern Europe and Georgia right
now they're both very pro-nationalists
pro-natalist countries that Argentina
guy right I mean I think we do see it on
an international scale and so they want
to be left alone but they are seeing
their values echoed other places yeah
but the the problem is
um these are all essentially what you
can just characterize the great men of
history there's one guy right it's one
guy who's like in Argentina I'm gonna do
all this stuff okay maybe you will be
like an Alexander the Great and you'll
conquer the entire Machinery of the
Persian Empire but if you fail that
thing is just gonna swallow you up right
and so you're putting a lot on one guy
like they don't have the organizational
capacity though let me give you another
historical reference to a conflict
fought over one group trying to be left
alone and one true uh one group trying
to uh control the other and you know
that that references in American history
it's a civil war okay the confederacy's
initial moves were a secession leave us
alone we out and they lost and then what
happened was the union said not gonna
happen yeah then this caused a major
Freak Out Among several more States like
Virginia which were they were they were
two to one in favor of staying with the
Union until Lincoln was like nah
actually we're gonna pull we're gonna
conscript people and we're gonna go
fight to suppress the Rebellion they
triggered more four more states to be
like this has to stop
this is funny because the Confederacy
could have won in the First Battle of
Bull Run but they chose not to invade DC
okay after the Confederates won and
shocked the North and pushed them back
they said that's it gentlemen we got it
now we'll be left alone and they were
wrong yes and then not not to say
anything like the Confederacy was
predicated upon ridiculous obviously we
don't support the Confederates ideas but
this is just an example from history of
how this works and that's the thing that
I'm really concerned about because like
like I just said the people who want to
be left alone they don't win the wars
well what's interesting though is the
people who want to be left alone we are
looking at a similar sort of situation
with the states rights fight because we
have a lot of States who are passing
laws that are Banning you know trans
stuff abortion
um yeah who are like making these
dangerously split it's dangerously split
but that's sort of what we're looking at
now that abortion is a states rights
issue the trans kids stuff is you know
no not elucidated in the Constitution
therefore it's a trans therefore it says
states rights issue and there's other
issues with that regard to education and
stuff like that so we are seeing things
solidify down States lines thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time